rushman congresswoman Alexander Ocasio
Cortez facing criticism after she made
this comparison the United States is
running concentration camps on our
southern border and that is exactly what
they are they are concentration camps
the fact that concentration camps are
now in institutionalized practice in the
home of the free is extraordinarily
disturbing and we need to do something
about it
after representative Liz Cheney
criticized those remarks Ocasio Cortez
doubled down tweeting quote hey
representative Cheney since you're so
eager to educate me I'm curious what do
you call building mass camps of people
being detained without a trial
how would you dress up DHS's mass
separation of thousands of children at
the border from their parents Dana I
just think it was a poor choice the poor
framing by Ocasio Cortez that allowed
and she said shrieking Republicans to
blow back at her but do you think that
she has a point I think she loves the
blowback this is like it's like her it's
like her fuel hmm right so it doesn't
care what she says I mean that was a
false and alarming it was a alarming and
false equivalence of the unparalleled
evils of what happened in the Holocaust
she says never again in her em in the
original comments and then later she
tries to vote no that's actually not
what I meant that that can work for some
people but and it some people will
defend you when you do that but there's
no there's like three Democrats who are
defending her so I think that's when you
know that you are out there on a limb
and then you're like Bugs Bunny you know
sign off the end I I think that Pelosi
as the speaker has a choice mate
remember they've had this several times
like are they going to try to get these
younger members in check
I don't think so I mean cuz AOC is night
she's her own phenomenon and I don't
think she minds at all the controversy
she does lets it roll right off her back
she doesn't mind that if what she's
saying is is a false equivalence
shouldn't care it actually fuels her all
right so let me go to the meg is
because Greg she said she's really
referring to an Esquire article in which
the political editor said a
concentration camp is not a death camp
not all Schwitzer Dachau but you know
where you as she said in the tweet there
where you simply separate and
concentrate a group of people I mean
she's she's basically playing with words
and how great is it that she's referring
to Esquire magazine for her expertise on
what a concentration camp is that's
called the media loop what's right so if
she refers to s Square and then Esquire
refers back to her and they just sit
there it's just a self-referential
massage who's a here's a question who's
a bigger expert on anti-semitism AOC or
Israel cuz right now she's criticizing
Trump right basically that's what she's
doing Israel just named a town after
Trump right I mean it's not it's not
Cortes Heights it's it's Trump Heights
case closed I mean what she did I this
is a measure of character look she she
throws she's a bomb thrower Trump's a
bomb thrower she's got a talent but the
fact is the talent has to be how to do
it correctly and she's got to own up to
her mistakes she made a mistake unless
she thinks like concentration and
concentration camp means thinking really
hard it doesn't mean that and by the way
buried in all of this is she has no
solution for these temporary encampments
which by the way Obama had as well and
used the same place which is if you
don't have a place to put these people
then they just come right in so you're
basically saying therefore no borders if
you're against just the temporary
holding and it so mean to the people who
work with these will work with the
people the agents I mean are they kiss
are they are they concentration camp
guards is that what you're inferring I'd
like to see her apologize
she should person up all right so Emily
the president tweeted overnight in
advance of today's rally that there's
going to be a mass deportation effort
led by a large number of agents in the
next week
apparently ice was surprised by this we
know that Kirsten Nielsen and Ron Vittal
were the former ice director both were
reluctant to do this that's why they
were forced out
but how does this fit into what Ocasio
Cortez is talking about because it
doesn't still fear in the immigrant
community I don't know how it fits in
other than she is failing at her job
which is if she has an issue with a
policy that she inherited as a lawmaker
then get off live stream and start
drafting a bill then change that policy
because my tax dollars are paying your
salary and you should earn that dollar
the policy of ice after final order of
deportation is such that within 90 days
they Institute removal proceedings and
unless the subject voluntarily basically
leaves on their own they actually have
no duty to do so it is ices duty to come
within 90 days in the Institute those
removals and you basically get a letter
in the mail and it says meet here at
this time and it's kind of like a self
surrender so if she is an issue with
that - then why don't you change it why
don't you garner some type of collective
cogent agreement on the hill rather than
loving your life streaming and not
knowing what you're talking about and
making inflammatory false equivalencies
that are horrendously offensive by the
way Jessie you know Emily makes a really
good point I think I saw in the polls
that seventy plus percent of Americans
think the dreamers should be allowed to
state sixty percent say the way that we
can deal with the border is to just have
more border agents more judges what do
you think well I think a hundred percent
of Americans don't agree with aoc that
were running concentration camps well I
hope and she's becoming more extreme
because she's running out of steam you
never want to compare anything to the
Holocaust it diminishes the genocide it
makes you look stupid she's only doing
this because she doesn't have a real
solution only things she's offered she
wants to abolish ice
she says global warming is pushing the
migrants north and she says we're
running concentration camps she's a
member of Congress we forget sometimes
because she sounds like a bomb thrower
on cable she can do something she hasn't
sponsored one piece of legislation at
all and now she's backpedaling and
trying to distinguish between it's
concentration camp versus a death camp
she's really losing this issue she's
dragged her party so far to the left on
impeachment on global warming and on the
border some of these positions
nationally that she's take them to are
unelectable and she's been sparring with
Pelosi her best friends have been
accused of anti-semitism you
on the whole maybe she offers a lot of
youth and enthusiasm fundraising fresh
glamour perhaps but on balance I don't
think she's been beneficial to the
Democrat Party Greg to your point the
vice president of the National Border
Patrol Council invited her personally
art doc wacho said please come down I
invite I will tour you around these new
facilities I think she should take him
and then she should live stream it let's
hear her thoughts yeah you knows at that
same time so everyone exactly unless you
vote exactly she won't go all right but
I think a lot of people have trouble on
the Democratic side with the way people
are treated at the border